like yasuhiro kubo here
going for a guinness world record title
he'll be free-falling from around 10 000
feet
and attempting to catch up with his
parachute attached to this canister
the record is determined by how long he
waits before jumping
at 50 seconds later off he goes
[Music]
well that was a relief and a world
record
[Applause]
free falling without a parachute is one
of the most dangerous stunts imaginable
do not even consider considering to
consider to do it
ever especially when even regular
skydivers have their off days
uh little help please bro
go on you can do it go on great
thank you all right
so how does a skydiver fall fast enough
to catch up with a parachute thrown out
nearly a minute beforehand
well to find out we need to brush up on
terminal velocity
and air resistance
as an object falls it collides with
trillions of tiny air molecules
resulting in air resistance
as the object accelerates the air
resistance acting on it
increases until it matches the force of
the object's weight
it's now at terminal velocity the
maximum speed it can fall
a larger surface area increases air
resistance and so decreases
terminal velocity a smaller surface area
decreases air resistance and so
increases terminal velocity
a skydiver in spread eagle position hits
terminal velocity around 120 miles an
hour
after about 12 seconds but for yasuhiro
to catch up with his shoot
that is just too slow so which of our
wannabe record breakers has remembered
how we speed up our terminal velocity
not these ones that is the complete
opposite
their raft has a large surface area
thereby increasing air resistance
and slowing them down
okay anyone else
yeah that's it going upside down and
reducing his surface area decreases air
resistance and increases terminal
velocity
trouble is oh whoa
it's very hard to control oh that guy
upside down too
yes he was once he's caught up with his
shoot yasuhiro needed to steer himself
into position to grab it
how did he do that well skydivers can
also use air resistance to maneuver
for example by adjusting his body shape
this guy deflects more air backwards
which pushes him forwards
bull's-eye somehow all of our high
flyers were fine
but i think we should leave the record
to yasuhiro
you